let's see if we can figure out what 2
divided by
0.1 or 1 10 is pause this video and see
if you can figure that out
all right now let's work through it
together and there's a couple of ways
that we can approach it one way is to
think about everything in terms of
tenths
so two wholes is how many tenths
well a whole is equal to ten tenths so
two wholes is equal to twenty tenths so
i could write the two rewrite the two as
twenty
tenths
and so that's going to be twenty tenths
divided by
and instead of writing it this way i
could instead of just writing it as zero
point one know this is the same thing as
1 10. so divided by 1
10.
and so if i have 20 of something and if
i divide it by into groups of 1 of that
something how many groups am i going to
have well i'm going to have 20 equal
groups of one so twenty tenths divided
by one tenth is equal to twenty
another way that you could approach that
is you could rewrite the zero point one
the one tenth as a fraction we could
rewrite this as
2
divided by
divided by instead of writing 1 10 like
this i could write it as a fraction
divided by 1 10.
well we know that dividing by a tenth is
the same thing as multiplying by 10 so
this is going to be equal to
2
times
2 times
10.
and that gets us to the same place that
we had before what is 2 times 10 well
that is going to be equal to 20. and
that's good that we got to the same
answer otherwise these would not be
equivalent methods
let's do another example
so let's say we wanted to figure out
what 6
divided by
1 10 is pause this video and see if you
can figure that out
all right
well you could do the same idea 6 wholes
is equal to how many tenths it's equal
to sixty tenths so i'll rewrite this as
sixty
tenths
divided by
one tenth
is equal to how many is equal to what
well if i have 60 of something and if i
divide it into groups of one of that
something i'm going to have 60 equal
groups of one so this is going to be
equal to 60. so you might see a pattern
when we divided by a tenth we end up
multiplying by ten when we divide by a
tenth we are multiplying by ten and you
could do the same thing as we saw up
here you could take you could say six
divided by one tenth is the same thing
as six
divided by
1 10 written as a fraction which is
going to be equal to
6 times you could say 6 times 10 or 6
times 10 over 1 either way
6
times
10 over 1
or which is the same thing as 10 which
is once again going to be equal to 60.
so i think you see the general pattern
divide by 10th same thing as multiplying
by 10.
now what about if we dealt with
hundredths so let's say we want to
figure out what
seven
divided by
a hundredth
is
what would this be pause this video and
try to figure it out
all right well we could do the same
drill
so
seven holes one whole is equal to a
hundred hundredths so seven holes is
equal to seven hundred hundredths
so this is equal to i'll write it like
this
seven hundred
hundredths
divided by
divided by one hundredth
one hundredth
if i have 700 of something and if i'm
dividing it into equal groups of one of
that something i'm going to have 700
equal groups so this is going to be
equal to 700. so you divide by a
hundredth is the same thing as
multiplying by a hundred now you could
also rewrite this as a fraction if you
like so that some of the principles we
saw up here still apply so we could
rewrite this as seven
divided by
one hundredth
and so this is going to be the same
thing as seven times a hundred over one
or seven times a hundred
seven
times
one hundred which once again will get
you to seven hundred so i think you see
a pattern divide by a tenth same thing
as multiplying by ten divide by a
hundredth same thing as multiplying by a
hundred